HALL BACK THE OTHER WAY AGAINST
TRAVIS HAMONIC.
EBERLE TIED UP BY NEILSEN.
MacDONALD GETS THE PUCK FREE,
BUT KNOCKED DOWN BY ARCOBELLO.
JUSTIN SCHULTZ.
CENTERING PASS!
THE FIFTH SHOT ON GOAL FOR THE
EDMONTON OILERS TIES IT UP AT
15:52.
HERE THEY COME AGAIN.
ARCOBELLO'S SHOT.
REBOUND, SCORES!
TAYLOR HALL HAS DONE IT AGAIN!
>> WOW.
>> TALK ABOUT A QUICK STRIKE
AFTER THE FIRST GOAL SCORED.
LOOK OUTSIDE OF THE BENCHES
RIGHT NOW.
ALL UP.
THE OILERS HAVEN'T HAD SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPEN IN AWHILE.
A GOOD JUMP OFF THE FACE-OFF FOR
EBERLE.
HE DRIVES THERE.
ARCOBELLO WILL GET ANOTHER
ASSIST HERE.
THE PASS COMES WIDE, HE CHOPS IT
TOWARD THE NET.
TAYLOR HALL DRIVING THERE, FINDS
THE REBOUND, AND STAYS WITH IT